Voiceover: I painted the F-111 in 1964.
F-111 was the latest American
Fighter Bomber in the planning stage.
Its mission seemed obsolete
before it was finished.
It seemed the prime
[forest] of this war machine
was to economically keep people
employed in Texas and Long Island.
At the time, I thought people involved
in it's making were headed for something
but I didn't know what.
By doing this, they could
achieved two and a half children,
three and a half cars, and
a house in the suburbs.
In the painting I incorporated
orange spaghetti, cake,
light bulbs, flowers
and many other things.
It felt to me like a plane flying
through the flack of an economy.
The little girl was the
pilot under a hair dryer.
The swimmer gulping air was like searching
for air during an atomic holocaust.
I had heard that the Chinese had
originally invented income taxes
as a donation to static community.
Now that taxes were in demand, I
thought if I sold this painting
the joke would be that the
buyer had already bought
a real F-111 with his taxes.
I was concerned with peripheral vision.
I wanted to specify that whenever
one looked at would exist
because of the peripheral vision that
extends from the corner of the eye.
Thus one would question,
one's own self-consciousness.
In the 1960s the painting was
critically taken as an anti-work protest
but there were a multiplicity of
ideas that caused its existence.